(prières chantées)
- Au son des prières depuis
quatre jours, ils sont des
milliers à venir se recueillir
dans ce parc du centre-ville
pour déposer une fleur et
prendre le temps de saluer
la mémoire de toutes ces jeunes
vies perdues. Parmi eux,
Eleanore, 12 ans.
Elle veut étudier, devenir
dentiste et elle ne veut surtous
à l'école. Sa solution :
davantage de contrôle sur les
armes à feu et plus de sécurité.
"Nous avons besoin de gardes
devant les écoles dit-elle,
pour que les enfants
se sentent en sécurité."
Troublée par le carnage de la
fusillade, Cindy, elle, est
encore sous le choc.
José est venu avec sa famille
pour témoigner de sa compass
aux familles des victimes.
Il se pose de sérieuses
questions sur l'inefficacité
de l'intervention policière
de mardi dernier.
Depuis que la police a reconnu
avoir eu tort de retarder
l'intervention pour neutraliser
le tueur de 18 ans,
la population d'Uvalde
en a gros sur le coeur.
Ils ont attendu trop longtemps
croit Randy Suarez. Des vies
auraient pu être sauvées.
Ils apprécient que la police
a reconnu avoir mal géré
la situation.............. Et ee
les résidents sont en droit
de savoir ce qui s'est
réellement passé. Jared Tommasi,
un vétérant de l'armée,
reste encore plus conciliant.
"Il va falloir tirer les leçons
degégégégégégédie", dit-il.
Mais il ne pense pas qu'une
autre loi pour élargir
le contrôle des armes à feua a .
(chants)
Face à cet état d'esprit, on en
prprprprprpresque à oublier que
les États-Unis comptent environ
330 millions de personnes et que
selon les plus récents chiffres,
il y aurait près de 400 millions
d'armes à feu civiles
en circulation.
Ici Frédéric Arnould,
Radio-Canada, Uvalde.